So I'm curious to see what unique
ingredients
Giorgi will be able to bring to the table,
literally.
Ow.
[Speaking Portuguese]
One of the most special species
in the rainforest.
The name is capicoba.
That's pretty, huh?
For you-that looks like that
looks very beautiful on a plate. Oh.
Hmm. This is good.
It kind of tastes like apple
skin mixed with black pepper. Wow.
Very specific, he’s
very impressed.
She looks like a green apple,
that's why she remembered the green
apple with the black pepper.
You know.
It's her look.
This is really fantastic.
I'm really excited
to get this into the kitchen,
and I want to start experimenting with it,
because I'm always fascinated
and surprised when I come across
something that I've never had before.
So this is awesome.
Capicoba was a great start.
Ooh, look at this.
But there was a lot more to discover.
Mmm. Very mild.
Very mild.
It’s not as fatty as a larger coconut.
[Speaking Portuguese]
Oh, it's like a wood ear.
Wood ear mushroom.
Mmm. Yum.
Is it a cannibal?
Plants?
Seriously?
We're going to get decapitated by a plant.
That's what I heard.
Just when I'm getting my groove, we come
across a poisonous plant called Criciuma.
That's crazy.
Oh, my God. It's a mad plant.
It's coming after me.
Are you serious? Yeah.
Don't touch it.
Oh, my gosh!
You can get hurt.
They say this plant can release
poisonous toxins that can burn you.
I'm not so sure it's true,
but I also don't want to find out.
Oh, no!
What do you think?
Do you think you have enough?
I like where we’re at.
Yep, It's definitely time to head out
and start figuring out how to work these
ingredients into our menu.